so yes godzilla versus comments out in
theaters and hbo mats
finally the wait is over and god damn it
was awesome
so for all you who haven't seen it yet
then do you watch it at the earliest and
do spend a bit of money on this
since the future of the most verse is in
your hands sure warner bros the power of
the people
democracy yeah anyway spoilers alert
this video will be an analysis of the
movie a breakdown if you will
and with easter eggs and other
information so let's get down with this
sickness
oh but do remember to click that
subscribe button to be a part of the
mind cue family
and ring that bell button for regular
updates on upcoming mini breakdowns
in detail the intro scenes of the movie
shows kong trying to break the barrier
this is a result of an unprecedented
change in the storm that surrounded
skull island
which changed as a result of human
interfering with the environment
and the hollow earth tunnels within the
island so
kong was contained in a biodome that was
designated as outpost 236 which means
outwards 33 that was the previous
monarch station in skull island
had been destroyed then right after that
we get into the intro credit scenes and
just as the previous movies there were
hidden information
that is whitewashed which we will show
in upcoming videos
then we head off to apex cybernetics in
pensacola florida
and the introduction of this
organization slash corporation
which were experimenting on robotics and
titans which then leads to godzilla
attacking their facility in pensacola
it is also at that time that we see
mechagodzilla's eye
which is meant to be transported to hong
kong the easter egg here is that
godzilla is seen as the bad guy
like the original and earlier touhou
movies and also another one
as mark russell to exclaim that
creatures like people can change which
is an easter egg
in itself for godzilla turning into a
hero from the original villain
incarnations
but here it's quite the opposite then we
see the head of apex cybernetics walter
simmons
along with the son of ishiro serizawa
who is ren sarizawa
recruiting nathan lin to travel to the
hollow earth to find a power source that
would be used to power the world
and fight the titans they were able to
visualize the whole earth through
magnetic imaging which would make sense
as anything with
electromagnetic waves would not be able
to penetrate deep enough
and also seismic waves wouldn't be able
to go right down
and be that accurate and in it they
discover a power source that has
600 plus gigawatt hours which doesn't
really sound
much like a savior or even much for
anything global
then we get to the ocean scene where
comb is transported in a large container
ship
and is dropped with sedatives up to 88
and let us chat on the important points
which were the atavs getting renamed to
hollow earth
aerial vehicles instead of anti-gravity
vehicles
during the journey they were in a
constant fear that godzilla might track
and attack kong by monarch studies they
have discovered that these species
have an ancient rivalry and that their
ancestors had a war
then the surprising part of kong being
able to understand and even respond in
sign language is seen
next we see madison russell and josh
valentine meeting bernie
and trying to understand the motives of
godzilla as to why he's attacking
humanity
and a connection with apex industries
now we get to the much hype ocean battle
scene
in the tasman sea but before that we see
another easter egg of
mechanic kong as a small toy beside
nathan lynn inside the ship
yeah mechanicong the villain that was
facing
kong in the 1973 or 76 movie
as seen in the trailers godzilla strikes
first flipping the container ship
upside down and during the initial fight
he even managed to draw first blood by
biting kong
when cor managed to turn back the ship
he realizes that godzilla would
come back and hence jumps ships to save
jia from the fight
the battle ensues and none of them gets
the upper hand until they both get
underwater and godzilla drags down
kong into the depths from which kong is
only saved by depth charges that explode
to disorient the g-man then later gaza
swims away after they turn off all the
engines to play dead to signal their
surrender
to the king of the monsters but not
before a final stare down between the
two titans
back to the other group comprising of
madison russell bernie and josh
they break into the pensacola apex
facility
and head down to sub level 33 where all
the action is
this is also another easter egg as 33
corresponds to the first giant monster
movie ever
king kong that was released in the year
1933
then bernie states that the place reeks
of breakaway civilization which is a
science fiction work on the secret space
program
run behind closed doors and select
number of genetically
determined individuals that are chosen
to colonize space
and exit the earth and it is in the
scene that we see the skullcrawler x
which means that apex played a part in
the destabilization of skull island
then we come to the antarctic scene and
it began with a major easter egg whereby
comb is transported by helicopters
which is clearly a reference to king
kong vs godzilla 1962 when he was
dropped
on top of mount fuji via balloons and
helicopters
it is here in antarctica where the
entrance to the hollow earth is seen
and this could very well be the same
place where monster zero was trapped and
awakened in king of the monsters
then we see them travel to the hollow
earth and through a wormhole like
phenomenon
where we get the interstellar kind of
vibe them being launched
thousands of miles in a couple of
seconds
so deep in the hollow earth the team and
kong witnessed a variety of creatures as
well as titans
the first were the small leaf wings
which were also seen in skull island
but they had a different coloration in
this place then there were the warbass
that fought against kong
and just got pulverized by the giant ape
and he actually ate the head of the
other one later we get to see two more
creatures in the vast plains of the
hollow earth
one were the crab like animals that are
only the size of a two-story building
and another one the bigger predator that
hunts them in packs
and these kind of look like a mix
between an iguana and a dinosaur
the last creatures to be seen in the
hollow earth are seen later on in later
scenes of the movie
and these are the hellholks and they
live in the throne room of kong
swinging like bats upside down on the
cave
back in the surface in the facility of
apex in hong kong
they unleash a skull crawler and this is
the red one
and it was very big bigger than the big
one of skull island
and it was killed in a sacrificial pit
that was testing mecha godzilla
this triggered godzilla to change course
from the south pacific into hong kong
into the apex facility located beneath
the victoria peak
kong then finds his throne room while in
the hollow earth and more
about it was discussed in detail in our
previous videos
so check it out about the kongs and
their technology meanwhile godzilla
makes landfall in hong kong
and would have been a couple of days of
travel for common godzilla
if you think about it um but here
godzilla census kong activating the
throne room
and shoots a mega atomic breath right
down into the hollow earth
so this triggers kong to come back up
and
fight godzilla and in the first battle
there were more blows from
kong and although godzilla also managed
to get some hits
it was kind of a tactical victory for
kong who used the surroundings and his
weapons
in a shock attack against the g-man but
in the second round godzilla managed to
dislocate kong's left arm
and then went berserk on the giant ape
crawling on all fours like
freaking exorcism kind of [ __ ]
terrifying even the titan kong
so the battle went to godzilla and he
comes out as the winner and khan was
left for dead
and godzilla continued on to the signal
that was sensed before
the mechagodzilla signal in the third
round mechagodzilla emerged from the
facility
beneath victoria peak and totally
dominates godzilla as the mecca was
powered by a synthesized
power source that was kind of infinite
and also the fight moves of the g-man
had been studied
by apex and monarch and the
counter-attacks had been
also pre-planned ahead of the takeover
begidoro's consciousness which also
magnified his
effectiveness to be fair godzilla had
been using his atomic breath for hours
on end
and the fight with gom had left him
exhausted and injured
but a team up with kong finally took
down the mechanical titan
and during the departure there was a
moment of mutual respect and recognition
which we first thought they were going
to fight again but thankfully not
so the movie ends with kong ruling over
the hollow earth and monarch
establishing a monitoring station to
oversee call
and still the only sign language that we
know kong can respond with is ho
ho and so with that we come to the end
of the video
do like subscribe and hit that bell
button for regular updates
on godzilla vs scandal section videos
take care fam